now bangladesh has sent troops to help
millions of people trapped by flood
waters in the northeast it's the worst
flooding in the region in more than a
century
and as tanveer chowdhury reports from
silette the government is struggling to
get drinking water and food to those in
need
shukrali is a livestock farmer who lost
his home in the floods he and his family
have been living on the side of this
road for almost a week now without any
kind of help
go and see the condition of our home
what is the point of talking about it it
is only allah who can provide he is the
one who gives and who takes away
[Applause]
sweetie beckham is waiting for
government assistance on the outskirts
of the city of silet after queuing for
hours she is beginning to lose hope
there is water all around my home chest
deep we've been sitting here waiting for
relief for hours and so far we've
received nothing armed forces have
rescued or evacuated more than hundred
thousand people from two of the worst
hit districts in the northeast many
others are still stranded in remote
rural areas
this is one of the many schools in sunam
gandhian silhouette region that has been
used as makeshift shelter for those
villagers were affected by the flood
most of the people took shelter on their
own now they're in desperate need for
food and fresh water
even residents in urban areas with
better drainage systems are affected
we've never seen floods like this in our
lifetime our home has water up to the
hip with no running water and
electricity we're now using rainwater
during her visit to the area prime
minister sheikh hasina said future
building developments should take into
account the number of natural disasters
that bangladesh experiences
many of these people are still
recovering from the last month's
pre-monsoon flash floods
we left our home to take shelter here
there's no food or fresh water it would
help if we got some relief from the
government so we can get by
for the poor rural farmers who have lost
everything it will take months if not
years to rebuild their homes they need
all the assistance they can get but help
is yet to come
now in neighboring india dozens of
people have died in flooding and
landslides in assam state soldiers have
been deployed to get supplies to areas
that are cut off
tens of thousands of people have already
been moved to safety but many are still
stranded
pavni mithal is in sibachar
district and joins us live from there so
is help now reaching some of those
stranded people
well the situation is quite dire there's
incessant rainfall over on the hilly
side of assam and that's causing rivers
downstream to swell and cause new rounds
of flooding and that is complicating
relief and rescue efforts so a lot of
people have had to look out for
themselves i mean we're coming to you
from an embankment and as you can see on
my right that is a makeshift camp and
people are living here and that is a
scene we've seen across the state people
here are villagers they've come from a
nearby place that is now almost
completely underwater
and as you can see that is actually a
field that is covered with water and
those are the makeshift rafts that
people here are using to go back and
forth to get supplies and food they say
they haven't really received much food
and relief and are looking out for
themselves we've seen them chopping wood
they're making fire so they can cook
there's a lot of concern about potential
diseases that these floods could bring
so people here say they sent their
children away to relatives homes that
have not been impacted by the flood but
what we've really picked up during the
course of our reporting is a lot of
anxiety amongst people you know these
people are farmers like most people in
the state and they say that these floods
have coincided with sowing season and
whatever little crop they have is now as
you just saw completely underwater so
they don't know when they'll be able to
make a living next now to be clear
floods are an annual affair in assam and
the ecology and economy of the state
need some level of flooding but
residents say they haven't seen this
kind of flooding in many years this is
the second major round of flooding
they've seen this year the first was
back in may that was caused by heavier
and earlier than usual pre-monsoon
showers
so officials we spoke to at the time
also said they were gearing up and
stocking up for another round that we
are in the middle of right now but there
are many challenges the military has
been called in we've been on rescue
boats and seen how they're saving people
but a lot of people are not really
willing to leave their homes they
they don't want to leave their fields
they don't know when they're going to be
back and when they'll start rebuilding
their lives across the state the number
of people affected by these floods is
rising it's now crossed five and a half
million people and over the last 24
hours seven more people have died
so they got a lot more flooding than
usual what is going to happen to people
who are going to be displaced for longer
than usual
well that is the big question and that
is what they're anxious about there are
relief camps more than 1600 camps have
been set up across the state and they're
housing more than 250 000 people but
most people have basically been left to
do what you can see here and because the
situation is really changing authorities
and people are really struggling i mean
just uh
a few a kilometers down this embankment
was actually breached uh yesterday and a
relief camp was swept away so people
have had to move and set up a home or
set up camps on a national highway that
is also now a submerged in water
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much